he is the new head coach of the
washington football team spent nine
years with the panthers ron rivera
joining us
on the program do you got business cards
made up coach that say
head coach of the washington football
team no not yet dan we've had to uh
we're going to have to get those changed
over and um
again it's you know it's an opportunity
for us to to really think about what we
want to become
and uh go forward you know what what
we've done is we've pretty much put a
placeholder
uh in in place and and it allows us to
really take the uh the
the 12 to 18 months it's going to take
to do this right
how involved are you in this i'm very
involved you know
um mr snyder and i talked before the
july 3rd announcement that we were
we were going to take a deep dive into
into our name um
and what it's going to take to change it
uh then on the 13th you know
we talked about coming out and
announcing that we are going to retire
the name and the logo and then yesterday
salem's been on the 23rd basically
telling everybody that
because it's going to take us 12 to 18
months to do this right
we're going to put a placeholder in
place and and again we're going to call
ourselves the washington football team
for at least the year
we put out what the uniforms are going
to look at look like they're very clean
it's been fun because our players have
reacted very well you know
they like the clean look they like the
fact that we've kept the the burgundy
and gold
i mean i think the big part of that more
so than anything else is you know
there's so much history and tradition
with the colors so we want to at least
make sure that that stayed
in our alabama players seem to like the
fact that uh you're gonna have your
their numbers on the side of their
helmets
you said that this might be two years
well it it it just it's going to take
time obviously you know we don't expect
it to take two years but it it
is it's a process and we're going
through the process we've gone through
the first few steps
you know we have a firm that's uh
involved
and you know they're they're taking the
dive with us they've been very
very thoughtful they wanted to make sure
they're very inclusive in in in the
activities that they're doing to try and
determine you know what's going to help
us determine what's going to be the best
name for us going forward
you know this is a name we want to stand
as mr snyder said for at least
100 years it's tough enough to win in
the national football league you know
that as a player you know that as a
coach and then you walk into a situation
like
this you got a second year quarterback
you got drama here
with everything i mean it this is
difficult and then you become
the de facto spokesperson and you've
only been there six months coach
like this is tough yeah it is but but
also
if we do this right this is something to
help galvanize us as well you know can
galvanize
not just the team but the organization
and not just the organization
but the community and again if we do
this right if we present this in the
right fashion
if we go out and do the things that
we've told everybody we're going to do
you know we're working on changing the
culture creating a positive
workplace environment for our employees
you know something that we can all be
proud of and come to work and do things
the right way
you know draw the community together as
we go through this rebranding process
we need to do that we need to do it the
right way and we've got to do it the
right way because again
there's a lot at stake in terms of of
not just the football but the
organization and the community as well
he's ron rivera he spent nine years with
the panthers did you bring any uh
panthers gear
with you to uh washington i did i've got
some um i've got some memorabilia i've
got some some great photos you know some
of the
from the great players that i had an
opportunity to coach and be around
but no team gear no no team gear
no team gear well you know we had a um
we had a um
a yard sale no we did we raised 30
000 it was um it was tammy reed's idea
she called stephanie and said you know
when we left philly we had a yard sale
we made a lot of money and gave to
charity
well stephanie came up with the idea we
work with the humane society of
charlotte and we did this
uh three and a half hours we made we
raised thirty thousand dollars and went
directly to the humane society of
charlotte so it
you know even though i let go of a lot
of personal stuff um
it was kind of it was cleansing as well
it really was how about the redskins
have a yard sale we've talked about that
believe it or not we you know because
because a lot of that stuff is iconic
you know and and there are there's a lot
of people that really believe
in the name you know just because of the
history of it and you know and
and and it was an organization that was
revered uh we we believed you know
and i did because i was one of those
guys i grew up with the redskins and
believe me that that was an iconic
um um name and and the logo was iconic
you know it
it's an actual indian chief and so
you know i treated it with reverence
with respect and uh
there are a lot of people in in this
community that still view it that way
but
you know knowing how it it it affects
some people in the community
it's one of the things that we realize
that we have to go forward and we're
going to go from here
when you saw the cam newton sign with
the patriots your reaction was
what i was excited i really was because
you know i thought all along that you
know that there were a couple teams that
were
would have been really good for him and
i always felt the patriots was one of
them
when when tom brady went to tampa bay i
thought you know what
that might not be a bad spot for him
because of the style of offense because
of
the things that they asked the
quarterback to do but i what am i
missing though with that coach because
we kept saying
he's not a backup quarterback i mean cam
newton is you know he's a starter he's
not going to be a backup quarterback
and then he had these workout videos so
i don't know if teams weren't able to
kick the tires because they couldn't
physically
you know meet him but he by all accounts
he looks great so i don't what am i
missing here that other teams didn't
want to
bring him in well i think not being able
to really look at them bring them in and
work them out i think they had a lot to
do with it i mean
think about it you know for the last two
seasons he's struggled with the injuries
he really has and
you know and not having him at 100 not
being able to play his best i think
reflected that way and a lot of folks
didn't think you know well maybe he's
lost it
but the one thing i've always said is
don't bet against cam especially when he
has something to prove
you know i thought in in 2015 coming off
the 2014 season him though we got in the
playoffs in 2014 he didn't play his best
2015 he played unbelievable in 2016 he
had an off year he was hurt
came back in 2017 and had had just a a
great year to got us into the playoffs
and then in 18 and 19 he was hurt
and so i think he has something to prove
i think he's going to prove something
i like the fact that coach belichick and
and and what they want to do offensively
i think that's going to suit him
and plus i think josh mcdaniel is
creative enough to use
cam's skill set uh to the best of his
ability so i i'll watch them i'll be
excited about watching them i was
always wondering about the rules with
quarterbacks and i don't think they
applied to cam the way they did other
quarterbacks and i don't know if his
size his athleticism worked against him
because
i i was there at that denver game they
beat him
up i mean i i thought that there should
have been guys who should have been
fined or rejected
they were targeting him yeah so now
that's how i felt i mean again that's
just my opinion
but you know the the rules you know to
me he was always i always thought he
kind of got the shaq treatment
you know when shaq used to get hacked
underneath and he didn't get you know
the fouls weren't called but
somebody else could hit that way and
then the flags would come or you know
the penalties would be called
i i i will say as you look at the the
young quarterbacks that are out there
now i mean i know michael vick set the
trend
and then all of a sudden you've got cam
newton out there now you've got the
patrick mahones you know and and you
look at what he's done and how he's done
it
you know these these big strong athletic
quarterbacks that are tough to bring
down that can extend plays that can move
around in the pocket
and create those are the guys that are
going to become dangerous you're going
to see you know the
the the passing of the torch in terms of
the style of quarterbacks because
you don't see a lot of aaron rodgers
coming out or
or tom brady's anymore you know you see
these veteran i'm
these types of guys are are going and
these athletic young athletic guys
are really i think coming to to to the
front uh i had an nfl scout who said
that you know when a coach takes over a
team the first thing he looks at he
wants to know who his quarterback is
and if you're sold on that quarterback
so at at what point did you see enough
where you said
hey dwayne haskins is going to be my
quarterback
well i've seen enough to say that he's
going to compete to be our quarterback
um if you really go down and you watch
those last four games that you started
and played you feel pretty good about it
you really did i did that's for sure but
as i said though i'm not saying he's our
starting quarterback
what i am saying is he's in position to
be our starting quarterback he showed
enough that i believe that we have to
give him a look
and and and and beyond to be very honest
that's why i didn't jump out and try to
get cam signed right away because i have
to watch dwayne and see where he is i
can't stun his growth
we've got to give him the opportunity to
to show us what he can
or can't do i agree with you on that the
last four games i saw something there
and but i didn't see that earlier like i
i think jay gruden kept saying he's not
ready we don't want to put him out there
and then he got out there and he didn't
look good at all but the last
month of the season then i go there's a
chance for him
a chance for him to succeed well you
know when i got to carolina
and and the first thing that marty
hernia and i talked about was we have to
establish who are who our quarterbacks
gonna be
is it on the is he on the roster is he
in free agency or will he be through the
draft
and we saw cam and we saw everything
that cam did
and we said this is gonna be our guy so
we had a plan going in
to have cam as our guy he you know i
named him the starter early on in camp
we worked it that way with him you know
he took the bulk of the reps
and then once we got started he took
every rep you know when you have a
derrick anderson as your backup
quarterback who doesn't need reps cam
got
every rep i mean you know we had this
little saying that guys have to get 5000
reps become before things become natural
and really what happened was by by the
end of cam's second year when we started
to ascend
that's when you really felt okay this
guy's going to be who he you know who we
hope he's going to be and then
by our third season you know we have our
we have our our playoff run
uh and and it really showed you were
drafted by the bears
uh 1984 of course played with that uh
great bears team that won
the super bowl what's your favorite
story that you tell from that uh chicago
bears experience
can you tell well uh there's a lot of
great stories uh but
you know um more so anything else i talk
about the memories i talk about the guys
that i got to be around you know hang
out with dan hampton and play golf with
him and and
you know be around steve mcmichael and
and learn from mike singletary
and and watch how great a teammate that
that jimmy mcmahon was
you know um got to know some of those
great offensive alignment that we had
and watched guys like jimbo cover get
into the hall of fame last year i mean
there's so many great things that that i
was fortunate to be
be part of um you know um uh one of my
favorite things that
i always tell story about is after coach
dick came back from his heart attack
and the players found out he was coming
into the facility uh
dan hampton and stephen michael ran
upstairs went into his office
opened up his good wine and started
smoking his cigars in his office and
coach dick walked in and saw the two of
them sitting there and
he had a few few choice words for them i
mean they were his favorites they were a
couple of his favorites and he kind of
let them get away with it but it was
pretty funny
and then he told us the rest of the guys
don't any of you guys get get any ideas
all right
that sounds like something mcmahon would
do um
yeah yeah it probably is but um i don't
think i don't think jim's a wine guy
i know he's not he's he's he's certainly
a beer guy
yes he is and maybe some other things
that he might smoke but uh
that i mean you were there uh your
rookie year is when peyton broke the
yes the rushing record as well you know
walter was was was one of the really
great ones i mean he really was
uh and he had it and what was really
neat though was the way he he included
everybody i'll never forget when he
first met my mother and father and the
way he treated him from that point on
it was like he knew he had known my dad
for for 20 years
and every time he'd see my dad he'd take
my dad over hey let's go get a beer geno
and he take my dad and you know buy him
a beer it was really cool
and he's also was really instrumental in
me starting my coaching career
he had gone to ed mccaskey to get me a
coaching job
with the bears and what happened was mr
mccaskey brought me in
on on walter's request or direction and
i sat down had a great conversation
and and and the following year uh after
the season was over
i i met with dave wanstead and coach
wants to give me my first chance and and
it was it was an amazing thing and the
rest is history from that point
that's pretty cool he's the the head
coach of the
washington football team he's uh ron
rivera i
applaud you i said this a week ago that
you're the spokesperson i don't think
it's fair that you're the spokesperson
but you're the stand-up guy there
and you're taking it all upon yourself
not many coaches are
able to do this and probably willing to
do it so i wish you well
ron it's tough enough to win in the nfl
but you got some other hurdles to uh
overcome and we appreciate you joining
us oh thanks dan i appreciate being on
it's ron revere